[Music]  I'm really happy to see you looking  great and good everything good with you  yeah you know you you just continue to  amaze me because like you've gone  through this transformation but you've  been so open and vulnerable why'd you  decide to just kind of let us get into  like everything you've been wanting so  people are true yeah when you were on  Wendy and you were talking about the  fact that you and Rob didn't have a  relationship before I felt like I really  saw hurt in your eyes he's going through  it right now would you reach out to him  or would you also wear my prayers are  with them when you saw all that what did  you think when we saw that the social  media crazy I mean is disappointing but  you know do you think he is mine yeah  pretty sure yeah are you house what does  happiness look like for Lamar Odom right  now um sober and free happy  [Music]  you